Cái quý vị chỉ còn cho đây 2 ngày nữ ở bức săng tết hay gửi không trăm 2 mi sống
Không phía tết ngừa đàn bính họ,
cải cắt trở và các thị trường thì emu sấm tận dự hút cho đất bắt đầu giảm nhật rồi
các tiểu thương cũng đã hạt ra đây thu tên về chuẩn bị về quen tết
Năm nay, trời ấm nên đảo tết độ sống không còn nhiều kê đẹp để bắn
Chồng khi giá lại tăng băng ngơi tới búng tình trăm, sau bánh mọi năm,
đoàn hình hình của thiên tay, nên mọi người ngừng ngừng ngẹo à cũng không mấy hận mà
Điễn ngừng hôm nay thì nhiều người bắn đã phút định bắn dẻ để trụ búng về
Thuy nhận tại các trở trong sáng nay, bắt hàng trái cây bắn còn khán nhỉ
cho thử xe cua dạm xe đế mọi năm
Cái giá hoa của à cũng đã bắt đầu dạm xe cua mình nghĩa trước
Chỉ còn hôm nay và ngày mấy đề sấm tết, người mua có nhiều thời gian hơn để thông thạm
ngắm nghĩa chỗ lùa và mất cả, còn nhai bắn bị đạc đủ bán thơp anh nhé
Để con giọng sẹp đông có hế việc của anh tích
Đó cũng là đi gió, giá các mặt hàng ngoài trở có suyến dạm